because you know you're very successful
stand-up and you're working at a certain
level you think every gig will work but
you still have what difficult gigs where
was the Charles and Camilla one was at a
pokey and Palace it was at Kensington
Palace and it was this weird gig that
they do once a year for all the staff of
Kensington Palace and I know some other
people that have done this this show and
they have a magician one year a musician
comedian and I went and I did this this
show Kensington Palace and it was the
staff and then Charles and Camilla in
the front row literally sat in Thrones I
mean it was like the closest it could be
to being the court jester on stage and
it was it was horrendous I died so and I
was trying to like I remember Prince
Harry was out in Afghanistan at the time
so I was like you know I was like um I
just want to say you know Prince Harry
out in Afghanistan that's that's so
brave of him a ginger in that heat went
down like a dead Corgi and then
afterwards the one little bone that he
threw me as I met Charles afterwards and
he just said you were a lot better than
the contortionist that we had last year
[Laughter]
amazing to think of the year before
which I wasn't given to us out there in
their Thrones as a guy climbed through a
tennis racket
hey don't dis contortionists I just your
your your wife is she contortionist my
dear wife is yes she was in the control
she she was in the Olympic she was she
was a rhythmic gymnast and she was in
the Olympics in Sydney in 2004 Canada
there's yes there she is that's my
darling Emily and then she expanded her
training to include Cirque de Soleil
kind of aerial things and she does in
fact last year she doubled Emma Stone in
la-la-land all that aerial dancing
outside the scene in the planetarium you
know that's her did you know dancing you
know can she do a contortionist I can if
you go on holidays could you get in a
suitcase that kind of thing
she was a magician's assistant oh yes
and [ __ ] so she will you packed herself
away in a box that's right she did that
and she's quite quite bendy and our
first we met at the gymnasium and I saw
a guy started a conversation I saw her
doing wonderful things and I played jazz
piano and there we were
Oh her name is Emily I think III if
you're watching Greg reporter I'll bet
you know this old standard called Emily
I sang to her Emily yeah
as the murmuring sound of Maine and I
said hey Emily you want to come up and
do contortion on our piano we had a
grand piano she said yeah she came up I
said what we play guys what do we play
they said all that moved for a Fabulous
Baker boys remember when Michelle
Pfeiffer does to makin whoopee but he's
okay and she got up and she did this
amazing routine that was the two days
after we met we're still very much in
love six years now we have two children
one two and a half and one six-month-old
one two boys yeah how long
[Applause]
you
[Music]